ladies and gentlemen scamming has been
around for a very long time so has speed
running but i'm happy to say a new sport
may be emerging here nft speed run
scamming is now here thanks to john wall
let's begin start the timer now
john wall said on september 15th i'm
hopping into the nft wave what are some
projects i should look into oh boy
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
copyzilla and today we're talking about
the nft scam speed run guys i told you
it's a new sector so we don't have a lot
of established times here the timer is
hopefully going right now uh but john
wall is putting in first place right now
it only took him an astonishing seven
days to go ahead and create his own nft
project after telling everybody that he
knew nothing about nfts this was
announced a week after he said i'm
hopping into the nft wave he took seven
days to study the market and realized
what everyone realizes which is this is
just right to uh give a fiver artist a
few bucks and then go ahead and launch
your own scam so look at this proud to
announce my very own baby ballers us nft
raising 100 000 to give to charity and
my ballers community and then we see the
beautiful artwork that is going to going
to launch them to the moon and i want
you guys to all take in this glorious
piece of artwork and ask yourself have i
seen any part of this
before and if you're thinking yes you'd
be correct that is in part because um
well people notice this looks almost
identical to the boss baby but also that
his background is ripped straight from
fortnite ladies and gentlemen let's give
it a hand
for the speedrunner john wall this is an
impressive level of um copyright
infringement and just general laziness
you just steal your background from
fortnite fortnite nfts guys
and of course it's a basketball court i
guess because john wall is a well
basketball player you guys know how it
is when you're a basketball player or a
rapper
or an influencer there seems to be some
kind of compulsion to get into every
kind of money grab you can is it crypto
is it nfts i mean it really doesn't
matter as long as you're taking money
from your fans um in as blatant of a way
as possible that's really the goal now i
want to point something out here which
is basically
that of course i don't believe all nfts
are scams but what is going on here
ladies and gentlemen is just the laziest
most blatant out there i'm just gonna
take your money scams right now these
people couldn't have even read the
wikipedia definition of an nft before
they launched their own projects and
people's about buy it now interestingly
now that he's been caught um doing this
with the fortnite background he's
removed the background from his tweet
never addresses it never talks about it
that he just got caught red-handed
with stolen content uh yeah i'm sure
they're gonna blame it on their
designers oh and it looks like they are
already here's from their discord i
joined it of course i had to have to
check it out uh they said we've heard
the concerns with the community
regarding the realization of the
fortnite background used on the banner
and in the pieces of marketing content
firstly we'd like to apologize as the
team did not notice this once the
marketing designs were made
guys the designer's fault i'm sure john
wall had no idea you couldn't create a
piece of original content in seven days
from learning you had what nfds were and
then i love this pose which all of them
say please understand we have no plans
of making this the typical celebrity
cash grab that is sometimes seen in the
community do you realize everybody says
that every celebrity cash grab all say
is saying your typical celebrity cash
grab that's what all of them say it's
like saying this isn't financial advice
that is almost always preceded by
financial advice i mean i can't believe
anyone within the right mind would
believe this but then again there are
people who are still interested in
cryptozoo after realizing it's adobe
stock images so i guess these people
exist but if you want any more evidence
of just how sad it is how desperate
people are to make money both the nft
creators and the people flipping these
type of nfts these nfts i guess you'd
call them uh just celebrity backed you
know garbage products like this look no
further than the various channels they
have within their discord do you guys
see um this right over here this says
shilling template and yes it is what you
think this discord see john wall is no
idiot he knows that he has to get people
marketing and so what he created was not
only a fortnight background for people
to buy but there's also a shilling
template for the people who are going to
promote this thing because basically
they they financially incentivize you to
shield this product to your friends in
like a pyramid scheme like fashion so in
order to do this you got to pay
attention here they created something
called the early access role and so
basically you have to shield this
product to three of your friends and if
your those three of your friends join
you then get a bunch of uh what they
call daily giveaways apparently they're
going to give away aetherium and mints i
guess of other baby ballers so basically
they say look if you join our little
pyramid scheme you get three friends
those three friends get three friends
all of you guys are gonna get free money
basically what's happening i'm a
distributor charlie for a revolutionary
new product that changes lives and so
this brings us back to the shilling
template here you go this is so
basically say you don't even have to
think about how you're gonna advertise
this to your friends we've created this
for you and it says nft baby ballers
collection you just copy and paste this
total of collection of four thousand
mints available hundred thousand dollars
there blah blah blah discord your link
here this is how you promote it and then
um i guess you send them this atrocity
which i guess is supposed to get them to
like the project i'm not sure exactly if
somebody sent you this if they would
join the discord
or call the police i i honestly think
calling the police might be a a better
thing to do if somebody sends you a
bunch of cartoon children i don't know i
i don't think the first thing you're
thinking of is this is an nft project
worth getting behind but anyways
assuming you're dumb enough to get
yourself reported to the fbi by sending
a bunch of people um pictures of a bunch
of little cartoon babies then you can
get uh the proof of shilling server
that's where you go next where you
basically tell the mods that you've done
your due diligence as john wall's little
servant and you now are eligible for i
guess these giveaways whatever you've
you've entered the pyramid scheme you're
a beautiful person look at all these
people doing it i mean my gosh
everybody's interested in joining even
after the fortnite thing and so yeah
that's uh basically how this thing works
i mean all in all i would say a pretty
unbelievable scam to be created in such
a short time john wall definitely uh
well we can stop that timer now john
wall definitely deserves the title of
number one fastest nft speed run scam
never seen it before it's just the fact
that not only did he start an nft so
fast he didn't even know what nfts were
it'd be like if you didn't know what a
cell phone was and then seven days later
you're trying to start the next apple
that's why i created the freedom phone i
mean i'm not gonna say it's not gonna
work i'm just saying i wouldn't line up
to be the investor anyway that's
basically it i hope you enjoyed it more
madness in the nft world we will
continue covering it because to me it's
hilarious anyways i hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next
save
one
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as so you're saying no
you're not